[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 me acompaña en el estudio
como todas las mañanas a Marta Moya
Marta bienvenida buena mañana de
miércoles y vamos a empezar esta revista
de prensa comentando una extensa
investigación del diario español el país
junto a medio franceses y alemanes sobre
qué sobre la tragedia migratoria que
ocurrió el pasado 24 de junio en la
frontera entre España y Marruecos o
Marta sí Raúl buenos días Esta es una
investigación de El diario el País de
cinco meses junto a Lemon Der spiegel y
en ass sobre esta tragedia que ocurrió
el pasado 24 de junio en El Paso
fronterizo del barrio chino entre
Marruecos y España esta investigación se
compone de dos partes un documental de
17 minutos y una recreación visual y
cronológica basada en 140 vídeos en los
testimonios de 40 supervivientes y
fuerzas del estado y además una
reconstrucción en 3D
Qué pasó fronterizo del barrio chino
donde se produjo esta masacre para
hablar de los hechos nos remitimos como
decía al 24 de junio donde unas 1.700
personas según las autoridades españolas
intentaron cruzar el paso fronterizo al
país de el sur de Europa por el barrio
chino entrenador que es esta localidad
marroquí y melilla que es la ciudad
Autónoma española lo hicieron personas
la mayoría de nacionalidad sudanesa que
está sometidas a una represión brutal
por la junta militar Y por la amenaza
constante de la guerra civil en este
país en esta situación murieron 23
personas y al menos 77 siguen
desaparecidas y es el suceso más trágico
de los últimos tiempos en una frontera
europea Marta como repasa la
investigación la cronología de los
hechos de aquel día si Raúl pues
empezamos a las 8 y 18 de la mañana en
ese momento llega el primer grupo de
migrantes y refugiados al puesto
fronterizo algunos intentan saltar la
valla que colapsa y estas personas caen
al suelo en los minutos posteriores
cientos de personas ya entran al patio
interior del barrio chino de este puesto
fronterizo y los agentes marroquíes
empiezan a disparar gases lacrimógeno se
habla de que en 8 minutos dispararon
unas 20 bombas de gas lacrimógeno
mientras los migrantes respondían con
piedras y palos e intentaban forzar esta
puerta para Acceder al lado del paso
fronterizo español en esa en ese momento
se empieza a formar una nebulosa de gas
y humo en este espacio cerrado y cada
vez más gente se empieza a amontonar
para forzar la puerta del lado español
del lado español 12 agentes de la
guardia civil estaban disparando gas
pimienta a las 8:42 agentes marroquíes
irrumpieron en el patio y en simultáneo
esa puerta empieza a ceder y decenas de
personas se avalanchan allí no en esa
avalancha de personas empieza a formarse
ese embudo que causa decenas de víctimas
y empieza a generarse esa angustia Que
precede al caos de lo que ya vemos
después difícil situación en Marta que
se vivió el país también ha recogido
como lo estabas o comentando los
testimonios de una treintena de
supervivientes Sí hablamos de 35
supervivientes y cinco agentes del
Estado entre que reportan un poco lo que
vivieron en aquella mañana del 24 de
junio no es relatan que las autoridades
marroquíes en ese momento en el que cede
la puerta y empiezan a avalancharse el
único propósito era salvaguardar la
frontera y no las vidas de estas
personas no destacamos por ejemplo una
cita de uno de ellos de abule que dice
cuando nos caímos no pudimos levantarnos
más los policías marroquíes nos vinieron
encima Mientras nos golpeaban estaban
usando palos y un martillo la policía
pegó a la gente de una manera cruel
algunos murieron sobre todos los que
estaban encima de mí y como este pues
otros relatos supervivientes de aquel de
aquella tragedia no dice además que a
partir de las 8:45 cientos de migrantes
lograron entrar a la zona española de
este barrio chino y la policía intentó
contener a la mayoría y se enfrentaban
no ellos los migrantes con palos y la
policía con pelotas de goma y gas
pimienta algunos empezaron a caer
desmayados e incluso una ambulancia no
fue capaz de actuar sobre todo y aluden
a cuestiones de seguridad muchos
quedaron atrapados en el puesto
fronterizo
470 fueron devueltos arrastras o a
territorios marroquí y 133 lograron
saltar el cordón policial pedir asilo y
entrar a Europa allí relatan que se
quedaron hasta las 12 de la mañana Bajo
el sol maniatados y después los
trasladaron en autobuses hasta ciudades
de 16 horas en coche de la frontera
lamentable suceso cambiamos ahora de
tema aunque no mucho Marta Porque él se
hizo viral en las redes una fotografía
de tres Migra para un buque que
estuvieron viajando por 11 días desde
Nigeria hasta España y su final no
parece feliz rápidamente sí me
comentamos esta portada de la vanguardia
que además relata no que el ministro de
interior va a tener que dar
explicaciones por la cuestión de melilla
pero destacamos este titular una inútil
travesía de 11 días en un timón esta
foto de salvamento marítimo de España no
que ha circulado mucho en las redes en
las últimas horas donde tres jóvenes
embarcan desde lagos y llegan tras 11
días a Nigeria las costas O sea a las
costas de España después de pues estar
en un cubito un cubículo en esta parte
delantera del buque en un metro por un
metro y medio no un cubículo
estrechísimo y está heroica trayectoria
pues al final no termina bien porque en
la ley de polizones marítimas obliga a
que estos tres jóvenes que son los tres
mayor de edad sean deportados otra vez a
Nigeria Bueno después de todo esa
travesía Marta Muchísimas gracias Mañana
más revistas de prensa mañana y